Let's take a look at Lauren's example of ABCs in the natural environment. In
the first example, she talked about thirst. Thirst was our motivation. The
refrigerator was our cue, or discriminative stimulus. And the behavior was
grabbing a soda and taking a drink. And then we said the thirst is quenched.
But lemme ask you this. are we adding refreshment, or are we removing thirst?
In the second example Lauren says that we spit out the milk, because it tasted
bad. so here did we add an unpleasant taste, or did we remove a bad taste?
These are 2 good examples to demonstrate that sometimes it's difficult to
distinguish whether something is being added to the environment or removed from
the environment. But just remember, if behavior increases, it is reinforcement,
and if behavior decreases, it's punishment. We also want you to know that some
people in the field argue about whether or not we even need the distinction of
positive and negative punishment or positive and negative reinforcement, and it
is difficult to tell. For example, if you're cold and you put a sweater on, are
you adding warmth? Or you decreasing cold.